aux etats unis évacuation sans précédent
menacé par le cyclone katrina les
habitants de la nouvelle-orléans tite le
ville on craint des dégâts
catastrophiques l'ouragan classé
catégorie 5 le plus haut niveau pourrait
frapper de malagnou ziane un avion de la
compagnie turque cela hier cloués au sol
après l'inspection de l'aviation civile
plusieurs anomalies dont une fuite de
carburant et tdc c'est la seconde fois
en quelques jours que la compagnie
turque était pas nier la fin des
universités d'été du parti socialiste
dans son discours de clôture françois
hollande appelle au rassemblement et à
faire face au gouvernement le ps veut
préparer l'alternance de nic strauss
kahn est l'invité de ce journal la
chirurgie au secours de l'épilepsie
cette maladie concerne cinq cent mille
français les résultats des opérations
sur les enfants notamment sont
spectaculaires une nouvelle voie pour
traiter ce grave dysfonctionnement
neurologique puis du théâtre avec le
plaisir de retrouver sur les planches
jean louis trintignant
cette fois ci dans un registre on le
connais moi registre où l'humour et la
drôlerie traite de sujets sérieux comme
la vieillesse et la mort la pièce
s'intitule -2 elle est signée samuel
benchetrit
voilà monsieur bonsoir aux états unis
alerte rouge en louisiane la
nouvelle-orléans redoutent le passage de
l'ouragan katrina qui s'est renforcée
ces dernières heures au point d'amener
les autorités à une évacuation de la
ville on craint cyclones dévastateurs
classé désormais sur le plus haut niveau
de risque et des centaines de milliers
de personnes sont en train de quitter la
ville dans le calme
une ville qui se prépare au pire car une
partie de ces quartiers sont en dessous
du niveau de la mer ziigmund eux n'ont
pas attendu l'ordre général d'évacuation
ils se sont enfuis dès l'aube des
dizaines de milliers d'habitants ont
pris la route pour échapper au terrible
ouragan katrina
cette fuite a provoqué des
embouteillages monstres et ce n'est pas
fini car toute la population de la
nouvelle orléans doit maintenant quitter
la ville un demi million de personnes
est concerné
j'ordonne à tous les habitants d'évacuer
immédiatement la ville de la nouvelle
orléans
mesdames et messieurs j'aurais aimé vous
annoncez de meilleures nouvelles et nous
allons devoir faire face
l'ouragan celui que nous avons toujours
craint plus le cyclone katrina se
rapproche des côtes et plus il fait peur
il est maintenant classé catégorie 5 le
plus haut niveau sur l'échelle qui
détermine l'intensité des cyclones
katrina pourrait être le plus dangereux
pour les états unis depuis 1969
l'ouragan camille avait fait 256 morts
faut imaginer que des à partir de 240
km/heure on a une poussée de plus de 600
kg par mètre carré c'est énorme
donc effectivement des de tels vols on
sait qu'à ça casse tout sur son passage
peu de portes et de fenêtres résiste un
tel ouragan les bas quartiers de la
ville sont les plus menacés situés sous
le niveau de la mer ils sont protégées
par des digues de 5 mètres 40 dans le
meilleur des cas
or katrina pour et élever le niveau de
la mer de plus de 5 mètres 50
la ville se vide progressivement de ses
habitants sans panique apparente a
ordonné le trafic avancent lentement
ce qu'il doit faire et il y à quelques
minutes
le président des états unis a appelé la
population à se mettre à l'abri d'un
impossible de dire pour l'instant si
katrina restera dans les mémoires comme
l'un des cyclones les plus puissants de
ces dernières années les spécialistes en
tout cas le juge siens qui est temps qu
il le compare déjà à l'ouragan qui avait
touché les états unis il ya 35 ans
provoquant des dégâts considérables
retour sur ces phénomènes climatiques
hors norme jean françois furet
à l'expo ni charley dennis ivan jeanne
et maintenant katrina des prénoms pour
un phénomène meurtrier
voici un ouragan filmé de l'intérieur
par l'armée de l'air américaine
les vents tourbillonnants à 400 km il
dégage une puissance de 200 kilos tonnes
c'est dix fois la bombe atomique
d'hiroshima un ouragan ne se forme que
pendant les périodes chaudes quand la
surface de la mer atteint 27 degrés sur
50 m l'air chaud remonte entre en
collision avec les vents froids et donne
aux nuages un mouvement spirale un
ouragan a donc besoin d'humidité
voilà pourquoi il ne frappe que les
zones les plus chaudes du globe proche
de l'équateur comme charles et en
floride il ya un an
bilan 16 morts
en novembre 2004 aux philippines cette
fois les inondations qui avaient suivi
l'ouragan winnie avait fait plus de 500
victimes et au début de l'été
dennis balayé cuba plus de mille
ouragans sont recensés chaque année
mais on sait déjà que katrina sera d'une
puissance rarement atteinte
deuxième titre de ce journal il concerne
les avions à risque avec ce nouvel
incident comme une loi des séries mais
une affaire heureusement prise à temps
et qui montrent l'importance des
contrôles en question un appareil de la
compagnie turque flyers et qui après
inspection de l'aviation civile a été
immobilisé à roissy mercredi déjà un
avion de la même compagnie avait été
contraint d'atterrir après 20 minutes de
vol
gilles marine est frédéric basket
l'airbus a300 de l'aflyht air est
toujours cloués au sol samedi
les inspecteurs de la direction générale
de l'aviation civile avait détecté un
pneus défectueux
ils ont fait aujourd'hui une autre
découverte il ya des fuites qui sont
apparus de fuite en portugais de
carburants qui sont apparus sur l'avion
dont une fuite elle même
or tolérance sur aude au dessus d'un des
moteurs les 160 passagers ont passé la
nuit dans un hôtel en bord de piste cet
après midi ils ont reçu une proposition
du voyagiste partir le lendemain dans un
autre avion ou bien renoncer
voilà donc si les gens qui venaient il
faut remplir ça en fait
m sans problème le retour prévu le
dimanche est décalé au lundi des
employeurs apprécieront-ils cette
prolongation des vacances j'ai eu du mal
à les avoir maintenant
alors si en plus je vais prolonge dans
mais je vais finir l'anpe alors donc
s'écrire j'annule nous ont pas pris une
partie pouvait rentrer un peu plus tard
oui déjà le 18 août
un airbus de la flyer avait dû atterrir
d'urgence à budapest un moteur en panne
et puis deux autres appareils de la même
compagnie ont été immobilisés en france
à chaque fois les passagers ont déploré
un manque total d'information
cette nouvelle affaire intervient alors
que sera publié deux mâts la liste noire
des compagnies à risques la direction
générale de l'aviation civile et
l'organisme en france qui contrôle les
avions en partance ou qui font escale
mais d'autres pays sont moins scrupuleux
dans les contrôles les explications
nécessaires de l'ip v6 à des centaines
d'appareils aligné dans ce que l'on
pourrait appeler le cimetière des avions
c'est ici dans le désert californien que
certaines compagnies plus soucieuse de
la rentabilité que de la sécurité
viennent s'offrir à moindre coût c'est
carlingue d'occasion des appareils qui
reprennent leurs vols après réparation
nous la volonté de la france de diffuser
dès demain la liste noire des compagnies
interdites dans l'hexagone parmi elles
devraient figurer corio airlines air
saint thomas international air services
et air mozambique
mais il s'avère que les contrôles de
sécurité ne se pratique pas partout sur
la planète de la même façon et pourtant
tous les pays doivent obéir aux mêmes
règles internationales certains sont
même pointé du doigt l'afrique apparaît
comme le continent le plus dangereux
pour les transports il ya un suivi de
l'amérique latine et du moyen-orient
viennent ensuite l'europe et l'asie les
continents jugés les plus sûrs
l'amérique du nord et l'australie
le ministre des transports promet que
les tour opérateurs devront
prochainement et de façon systématique
indiquer le type d'avion et la compagnie
utilisé par les voyageurs
à paris et la solidarité s'organise pour
venir en aide aux rescapés de l'incendié
de l'immeuble du boulevard vincent
auriol chaque famille a reçu de la
mairie des subsides en attendant un
logement durable que la ville et l'état
se sont engagés à fournir dans les
délais les plus rapides possibles
dominique simba qu'elle à la solidarité
en marche au gymnase kellerman de la
nourriture des vêtements des jouets
depuis vendredi familles et amis se
relaie auprès des rescapés de l'incendié
des anonymes se sont également déplacés
hier j'ai apporté des vêtements de femme
parce que moi je n'ai pas d'enfant
moteur de noir je parle beaucoup de ce
qui s'est passé et que les gens fassent
un petit quelque chose
les proches sont venus en nombre entouré
ceux qui ont tout perdu
être l'un tout simplement dans la
culture africaine
une étape essentielle dans le processus
de deuil
à l'intérieur du gymnase le provisoire
s'installe en liaison avec l'état la
mairie de paris a remis aux familles d
enveloppe de 350 à 450 euros net global
pour assurer le quotidien la mairie qui
s'est également engagé à reloger les
familles durablement se trouve que la
ville de paris a acheté un certain
nombre d'immeubles dans les années
précédentes
il se trouve que les travaux sont en
train de se terminer ou sont terminées
ces immeubles
ces appartements vont être livrés que
nous avons donc des grands appartements
dans ces immeubles et que nous allons
naturellement contenu drame qui vient de
se passer
affecté une certaine partie de ces
appartements famille concernant une
centaine de personnes à reloger les
autorités municipales ont déjà prévenu
les familles ne seront plus regroupés
dans un même immeuble
l'instant est la mairie de paris nous
indique les rescapés visiteront des
appartements dès demain lors de
l'incendié qui a ravagé l'immeuble du
13ème arrondissement des policiers de la
bac se trouvait à proximité au moment du
départ de feu ils sont arrivés les
premiers sur les lieux avant même les
pompiers leur intervention était
précieuse puisqu'ils ont aidé plusieurs
personnes à sortir jérôme soûlard karl
gréco
huit ans déjà que le brigadier-chef
vendent miley et son collègue bruno
battent le pavé parisien chaque nuit des
policiers de la brigade anticriminalité
00h18 ce vendredi dans le xiiie
arrondissement appel au secours
énorme incendie des flammes des cris ils
sont les premiers devant l'immeuble
avant même les pompiers leur
intervention sera déterminante
quand on est arrivés sur les lieux dont
il ya des personnes qui voulaient se
jeter les étages nous on est restés en
dehors pour pouvoir se permettre
enfin surtout pour que les personnes ne
sais pas
huit personnes sont ainsi sauvés d'une
chute fatale
pendant ce temps d'autres policiers de
la bac se précipite dans la cage
d'escalier au milieu des flammes aux 1er
2e et défoncer des portes pour faire
sortir des personnes qui étaient à
l'intérieur et ils n'ont pas pu monter
au dessus parce qu'en fait le feu était
votre niveau du deuxième dans la cas
jusqu'à lisons pas pu monter au dessus
des collègues ont sorti cinq ou six ans
devant l'immeuble en flammes maryvonne
parvient à calmer les premiers rescapés
certains voulaient retourner vers la
cage d'escalier mais il est trop tard
dix sept victimes 14 enfants des
souvenirs tellement douloureux
la panique
quatorze vies sauvées grâce à
l'intervention des policiers de la bac
mais le bilan est lourd pour un incendie
dont l'origine est encore indéterminée
dans la cage d'escalier la police
judiciaire n'a retrouvé aucune trace
d'hydrocarbure ni câblage électrique
défectueux les investigations se
poursuivent dernier week-end de retour
sur les routes d es ralentissement
volontaire des grandes villes du monde
pour entrer dans la capitale
une journée classée orange par bison
futé apparemment les retours globalement
ont été étalés dans le temps
face à la hausse du pétrole la
limitation de vitesse est elle une
mesure d'économie nude est lancée par
dominique perben un ballon d'essai selon
le ministre
réduire la vitesse de 130 km heure sur
autoroute à 115 permettrait de dépenser
moins en carburant
le débat est ouvert benoît faiveley
marie kazan un panneau qui pourrait bien
disparaître pour mieux faire passer la
hausse du prix de l'essence le
gouvernement pense avoir trouvé une
parade perdurer un plein plus longtemps
en roulant moins vite c'est un fait
démontré si vous réduisez votre vitesse
de 15 km heure ou compenser la hausse du
prix du prix du fuel de ou du prix de
l'essence du prix du gazole
effectivement sur autoroute
une voiture qui consomme 7 litres 2 à
130 km heure ne consomme plus que 6
litres 5 à 120 kilomètres/heure une
baisse de consommation qui ne convainc
pas certains automobilistes
c'est vraiment important pourquoi ça pas
été conçu de laborieuses poser comme
question
ba soit disant que c'était pour aller en
vers la hausse du pétrole mais bon je
pense que au moins je vous le 8 et plus
seront simples mais pour réduire sa
consommation de carburant
il ne suffit pas de lever le pied
l'autoroute concerne que les gens qui
roulent sur autoroute alors qu'un bon
comportement un bon entretien et une
bonne attention à l'état de sa voiture
ça concerne tous les automobilistes
ça concerne pas seulement ceux qui
roulent sur autoroute en fait si les
conducteurs appliquer cette baisse de
vitesse sur les départementales
nationales et autoroutes l'économie de
carburant serait de plus d'un million de
tonnes soit l'équivalent de 30 millions
de plein or le parc automobile français
de 30 millions de voitures
l'économie réalisée par chaque
conducteur et donc d'un plein par an il
en faudra sûrement davantage pour faire
passer aux français le goût amer de
l'essence de plus en plus cher et c'est
la rentrée pour tous et la rentrée
sociale s'annonce chargée avec les
chiffres du chômage cette semaine le
premier bilan des 100 jours du
gouvernement villepin
les syndicats comptent faire entendre
leur voix sur des sujets majeurs comme
l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat et à
palau hervé potter en mars dernier
c'était le gouvernement raffarin qui
était conspué par les manifestants
six mois plus tard l'équipe a changé
mais les dossiers épineux s'accumulent
pour cette rentrée
tout d'abord le pouvoir d'achat déjà au
coeur des précédentes revendications
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence n'a
rien arrangé et pour le moment le
gouvernement ne prévoit pas de coup de
pouce général côté syndicats on réclame
donc des hausses de salaires ouvrons des
négociations dans toutes les branches
professionnelles où il n'y en a pas eu
réduisons les inégalités entre les
salariés des grandes et des petites
entreprises
faisons en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus de
salaire en dessous du smic qui est des
négociations dans le public et dans le
privé l'emploi ensuite cet été le
nouveau gouvernement a bénéficié d'une
bonne nouvelle une baisse du chômage en
juin mais celui ci reste supérieure à
10% et la méthode adoptée par l'équipe
de villepin fait grincer des dents
cinq syndicats viennent de déposer des
recours contre les contrat nouvelle
embauche c'est pas en regardant passer
les trains et 11 ans plus de flexibilité
c'est par en zinc politique à grains à
l'anglais a comme monsieur blair qu'on
arrivera à soutenir la création
d'emplois
c'est vraiment booster la croissance
économique c'est ça qui est nécessaire
troisième dossier les impôts certains
syndicats réclament une fille
qualité plus équitable l'ump elle milite
pour une baisse de l'impôt sur la
fortune
enfin les autoroutes le gouvernement
espère récolter au moins 10 milliards
d'euros avec leur privatisation
une opération qui ne plaît pas à tout le
monde y compris dans les rangs de l'udf
en tout cas le calendrier de cette
rentrée chargée mercredi publication des
derniers chiffres du chômage jeudi
annonce du plan de ville pas pour la
relance de la croissance
puis ce sera déjà l'heure des bilans le
8 septembre les fameux 100 jours du
gouvernement
sans compter la menace d'un grand
mouvement social sans doute fin
septembre début octobre
rentrée politique avec les universités
d'été à l'udf drôle d'ambiance gilles de
robien s'administre du parti au
gouvernement avait cette semaine
critiqué ouvertement françois bayrou et
son attitude de d'opposant systématique
à la majorité aujourd'hui devant les
militants les deux hommes se sont
retrouvés
emilie lançant décontractée pourtant
après avoir traité françois bayrou
d'autistes dans la presse gilles de
robien et ici en terrain miné
il ne peut pas faire trois pas sans ses
excuses aux rapports de raisonneur la
partager elle a même pas excessive elle
n'a pas arrêté sa main voilà ma vie
j'essaie d'être excessivement elle
exprimé la même idée
d'accord prendra ta femme france à
beyrouth autistes à sa mère ou le
contraire de l'autiste absolument pas
ils écoutent françois bayrou écoute mes
militants eux applaudissent poignée de
main pour les caméras avec gilles de
robien mais les deux hommes ne se
regarde pas on se parle tout le temps au
moins par média françois bayrou très
virulent cet été à l'encontre du
gouvernement revendique son droit à la
critique gilles de robien seul ministre
udf sous villepin parle-lui d'opposition
systématique et stérile voilà des mois
qu'il ne se parlent plus mais cette fois
ils déjeunent ensemble devant la presse
explications je n'ai jamais prononcés
d'oukases à l'égard de qui que ce soit
je veux de la clarté pendant très
longtemps
le centre a été accusée d'être toujours
mi-chèvre mi-chou rôle me semble-t-il
dans des périodes un petit peu difficile
comme celle là c'est à la fois que l'udf
gare de ses valeurs et que ces valeurs
aboutissent à une udf majoritaire avec
bien entendu une fidélité et une loyauté
par rapport à ses électeurs et du t2
la question est réglée mesdames et
messieurs bref officiel veulent pas de
querelles à l'udf
même si gilles de robien s'en va
quelques heures plus tard
voilà direction maintenant la rochelle
où s'est achevée l'université d'été du
parti socialiste dans un climat
d'apaisement tout cas sur le devant de
la scène
françois hollande dans son discours de
clôture appelé au rassemblement et à une
opposition musclée au gouvernement dans
un instant nous recevons dominique
strauss kahn nous en parlerons avec lui
mais d'abord la rochelle où lionel
jospin est venu en voisin il n'a pas
assisté au discours de clôture mais a
participé dans une franche bonne humeur
ou banquet républicain celle du thalbach
frédérick basile puisque le ps se
cherche et veut à nouveau gagner
certains militants pensent que leur
ancien meneur de jeu doit revenir comme
zidane en équipe de france hier soir ils
le lui ont même écrit sur une banderole
bientôt visible leur revient comme la
liberté
en fait ce n'est juste pas apporte son
soutien à françois hollande auquel on
promettait un week-end chaud finalement
il se termine dans un calme relatif même
les opposants à la direction on dit stop
aux petites phrases
le spectacle s'arrête et que les choses
sérieuses commencent
ça s'adresse aussi bien à lui je ne veut
stigmatiser personne que les choses
sérieuses commencent le patron du ps ne
demandait pas mieux ce matin il n'a donc
une cible la droite et le gouvernement
villepin dont l'échec selon lui est
totale
françois hollande demande à tous les
socialistes de viser dans la même
direction comme s'ils avaient remarqué
des francs tireurs du côté de chez
laurent fabius quand nous réservons aux
talents d'artificier à nous mêmes plutôt
que la droite alors nous manquons à la
fraternité élémentaires pendant presque
factice usage du mot camarade mais
surtout nous manquons à notre devoir
premier c'est comme moi passent pas
simplement parce que je suis premier ce
qu'était mais parce que je suis
socialiste je n'ai pas d'adversaire au
sein du parti socialiste
la scission du parti socialiste françois
hollande n'y crois pas même si la
famille est déchiré même si comme prévu
la chaise de laurent fabius est resté
vide et même si les contestataires qui
étaient présents ce matin sont restés
sur leur faim et les salariés dans leur
grande masse dans ce pays
ne nous reconnaissent plus comme porte
parole dont il ne suffit pas je crois de
rechapés de rustines et de tout cela il
sera question dans trois mois au congrès
du mans du programme est forcément aussi
des ambitions présidentielles plus ou
moins déclarés
derrière la bataille du congrès qui aura
lieu en novembre tout le monde a bien
compris ce week-end que c'est déjà le
coup suivant qui se prépare la
désignation du candidat socialiste pour
2007 deux prétendants semblent déjà en
campagne
laurent fabius et dominique strauss kahn
unique strauss kahn bonsoir on va nous
parler de vos projets de votre ligne et
j'ai envie de dire de votre programme
succès c'est officiel vous êtes candidat
à la candidature pour 2007
mais je vais vous répondre l'instant
mais vous savez à cette université ne
m'a pas parlé que de ça on a surtout
parlé des problèmes des français et les
difficultés de la rentrée des drames qui
l'ont émaillée bien sûr la mort affreuse
de ses enfants dans la salle du parisien
mais pour chacun des français les poèmes
la vie quotidienne des caddies au
supermarché qui sont remplis de
l'essence donc vous avez rapporté la
situation tout à l'heure et ce qui nous
est apparu quand même c'est que cette
souffrance qu'on voyait partout
conduisait peut-être une majorité de
français à vouloir une politique qui
soit une alternative à la politique
c'est déjà le candidat des ex strauss
kahn qui part annoncé le parti
socialiste que je voulais dire là
c'était que notre université d'été
montrent que le parti socialiste sera
prêt moi ce que je veux dire aux
français c'est que le passé cialis sera
prêt pour proposer une alternative à
l'or alors êtes-vous dans votre question
oui j'ai écouté les français j'ai
réfléchi et je crois que honnêtement ça
ne surprendra personne que en effet le
moment venu je fasse partie de ce qu'ils
soumettront suffrages des militants du
parti socialiste pour le pour le
représenter et pour proposer aux
français un modèle de développement
différent
un mode d'organisation de la france
différents que j'appelle un
développement plus solidaire alors si
vous voulez bien en quoi justement
êtes-vous
on dirait peut-être le mieux placé en
quoi êtes vous un meilleur candidat je
pensais bien évidemment à laurent fabius
lui se place et parle d'un coup de barre
à gauche
est-ce qu'il est plus à gauche que vous
est ce que vous êtes plus à droite
quel est votre différence au fond je
crois pas que ce soit une différence
entre un taux de plus à gauche ou plus à
droite je crois qu'il y à deux logiques
en incarne une avec d'autres françois
hollande bertrand delanoë martine aubry
jack lang
ces deux logiques c'est quoi c'est que
je pense que il faut s'opposer au
gouvernement françois hollande le
rappeler à l'instant c'est notre devoir
c'est notre rôle d'opposition mais il
faut aussi proposer vos pas seulement
s'opposer il faut dire ce que nous
ferions à la place et il faut proposer
de façon sérieuse
c'est à dire en clair en disant quand on
veut faire quelque chose comment le
financera c'est fini l'époque où on peut
dire voyage n'y a qu'à faire ça il ya
qu'à faire plus d'argent dans la
recherche et améliorer les universités
il ya qu'à aider les primes de logement
il faut dire comment vous avez
travaillez vous avez donc le prendre il
ya là un point très important qui est
que l'opposition au gouvernement c'est
nécessaire mais que le caractère solide
argumentée financer des propositions est
nécessaire les français sont prêts
soucieux du maintien des services
publics
ils doivent savoir évidemment comment on
financera comment l'impôt financera je
savais que ma question parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu de difficulté à
comprendre
laurent fabius lui dit coup de barre à
gauche oui je crois gauche toute
vous dites ça mais ce n'est pas tout à
fait mon cap non je ne crois pas qu'on
est plus à gauche parce qu'on se
contente de s'opposer je dis simplement
qu'il faut proposer puis y être
différent sans doute lui moi d'autres
voulons tous rassembler la gauche c'est
bien normal mais je pense tout bas parc
pour rassembler la gauche il faut
d'abord définir les positions du parti
socialiste ensuite allé en discuter avec
les autres plutôt que d'apporter au sein
du parti socialiste les positions de
ceux qui seraient éventuellement nos
partenaires et qui sont partis
communistes l'extrême gauche etc
donc il ya sans doute des différences de
méthodes alors question très concrète
est ce que votre candidature veut dire
au fond françois l'emmener est hors
course
non je ne peux pas dire cela françois
hollande a déclaré qu'il voulait se
consacrer au parti socialiste qui était
candidate pour les secrétaires je le
soutiens pour cela je me battrai autant
que je le pourrai pour qu'il reste le
premier secrétaire ce travail et ensuite
nous verrons
il tend devront trancher tel calendrier
l'appel n'a pas été fixée je pense qu'il
faut pas que ce soit trop longs car il
faut que les français sachent il
représentera la vie on verra les avis
divergent moi je suis plutôt pour le
printemps mais le plus
il possible pour éviter ce qui vient
pourtant ce qui est important ce n'est
pas vraiment y nettement c'est pour quoi
faire et moi ce que je veux être capable
de dire aux français ce soir n'ont pas
le temps c'est pourquoi nous avons
besoin d'un président de la république
en france qui présente une alternative
de gauche à ce que fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
merci à dominique strauss kahn d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions enfin
à part ton pour le front national
jean-marie le pen a prononcé son
discours de clôture il l'a fait de
l'immigration son thème de prédilection
des gens campagne lui pour la
présidentielle de 2007 arnaud boutet
mais didier robert à 20 mois de la
présidentielle
jean marie le pen ne veux plus que l'on
qualifie son parti d'extrême droite se
soucie d'arrondir les angles
cette quête de respectabilité son bras
droit bruno gollnisch ne semble pas en
faire une priorité surtout lorsqu ils
cognent sur l'anti racisme la religion
antiraciste mérite donc pleinement le
nom de sida mental le sida mental
la métaphore sur l'antiracisme n'a rien
d'improvisé ses destinées à empêcher les
français de critiquer le phénomène de
l'immigration
c'est destiné à détruire les défenses
immunitaires devant 300 militants jean
marie le pen dénonce lui aussi
l'immigration il tape sur le chef du
gouvernement est la fameuse échéances
des 100 jours les 100 jours de napoléon
en effet on le sait et monsieur de
villepin de personnes il y a consacré un
livre on finit havas perd l'eau puise à
sainte hélène en s'accordant trois mois
de plus il aurait pu trouver dans le
200e anniversaire d'austerlitz une
raison d'espérer
pour éviter d'aborder le sujet aux
tâches sa succession jean marie le pen
envisage de reporter le congrès du fn
après 2007
en attendant il reste le seul chef au fn
personne ne chantera le contraire
qualité à l'étranger avec en israël le
premier attentat suicide depuis
l'évacuation de gaza deux blessés graves
de nombreuses personnes en état de choc
le bilan aurait pu être beaucoup plus
lourd c'est airbus qui a été visé à une
heure de pointe à l'entrée de la
principale gare routière de beersheba
l'homme a actionné sa ceinture
d'explosifs dans la rue alors qu'il
était poursuivi par des policiers
une vingtaine de blessés le leader
palestinien mahmoud abbas a condamné cet
acte terroriste revendique elle il ya
tout juste quelques instants par les
brigades des martyrs d'al aqsa en irak
où maintenant la dernière version du
projet de constitution sa version finale
a été signé aujourd'hui par la quasi
totalité de ceux qui avaient en charge
la rédaction du texte
le président irakien affirme que la
constitution est prête et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un référendum le 15 octobre
prochain en france venons en à la
rentrée scolaire plus de 12 millions
d'élèves vont retrouver le chemin de
l'école
ceux qui pratiquent la semaine de quatre
jours on dira déjà rejoint leur classe
ou s'apprêtent à rentrer demain
c'est aussi la rentrée pour les
professeurs comme ce couple
d'instituteurs dans deux villages des
alpes de haute provence isabelle steiss
michel commun au village du castelet 209
habitants monsieur le maire est aussi
monsieur le professeur l'école est à
côté de la mairie de ce même bâtiment
monsieur garcia qui fera demain sa 32e
rentrée des classes
donc ça passe encore mais il faut que la
rentrée soit même plaisir si c'est un
plaisir pour atteindre 18 petites
chaises qui attendent 18 petits écoliers
de 2 à 6 ans une classe unique de
maternelle que l'instituteur accueillera
demain à 8h45 souhaitait d'abord la
bienvenue
je vais leur présenter les petits
nouveaux en bas se raconter ce qu'on a
fait pendant les vacances le remercier
ce qu'ils ont et ceux qui m'ont écrit
des cartes postales tandis que le maître
s'applique aux derniers préparatifs pour
les tout petits dans le village voisin
la maîtresse mme adam garcia est
impatiente de retrouver ses élèves du
cours élémentaire l'impression de
retrouver mes enfants qui sont partis en
congé quelques pâles qui reviennent et
on se retrouve en famille donc la partie
de titres est une maman 0,35
l'enseignement c'est de l'éducation mais
c'est aussi beaucoup d'amour power 2 les
99 élèves du cours préparatoire au cm2 a
pu michel madame garcia fera demain sa
27e rentrée et c'est tout un village qui
se réjouit ça fait plaisir quand
beaucoup d'enfants ça fait plaisir au
moins le village vit la récréation et
c'est merveilleux dernier moment de
détente pour monsieur et madame garcia
mais finalement quand on aime son métier
on est toujours en vacances médecine
avec l'ouverture à paris du congrès
international sur l'épilepsie les
neurologues du monde entier viendront
faire le point sur les façons de traiter
cette maladie qui touche cinq cent mille
francs c'est une maladie décrite comme
un coup de tonnerre cérébrale dans un
ciel bleu désormais la chirurgie peut
guérir elle fonctionne remarquablement
sur les enfants comme le monde ce
reportage de nathalie sapina car gréco
à voir loïc grimper dans les arbres
personne ne peut se douter qu'il ya
trois ans il était gravement malade
terrassé trois ou quatre fois par jour
par des crises d'épilepsie des absences
en fait ils allaient décrocher pendant
10 secondes 20 secondes et au fur et à
mesure que ça s'empire s était
accompagné de spasmes après avoir payé
les énormes et 9 heures au minimum la
maladie elle est en empirant les
médicaments n'agissait plus est l'état
de loïc fabre avait trouvé du
comportement et résultats scolaires
catastrophiques et des mauvaises mains
après l'autre allongées des vannes nat
car c'est une opération chirurgicale qui
a guéri loïc il y a trois ans une
épilepsie était provoquée par une vision
unique du cerveau très localisées
souviens c'était cette petite chose qui
est là devant qui déclencher des crises
et ben on a été juste enlever cette
petite chose que vous avez est donc
maintenant se nettoyer et de où tu ne
fait plus du tout maîtrise le changement
s'est opéré dès le lendemain radical
la preuve par le cahier de loïc son
écriture avant l'opération et quelques
jours après pour cette petite fille les
crises spectaculaire se répétait 60 à
100 fois par jour
elle aussi est aujourd'hui guérie après
une opération qu'on va enlever c'est la
région qui ne fonctionne pas normalement
la région épileptique
mais autour il ya toute une série d' air
cérébrale qui sont impliqués dans le
langage dans la motricité dans la vision
dans la lecture qui effectivement ne
doivent pas être endommagées par le
geste chirurgical
cette opération nécessite de longues et
complexes d'investigation trop peu
d'enfants bénéfique
aujourd'hui on est à peine à un tiers de
ceux qui doivent être réinvestis qui
sont réellement investiguer dans les
délais et les autres sont obligés
d'apprendre en faisant des crises 300
enfants épileptiques devrait être opéré
comme loïc chaque année ils ne sont
aujourd'hui une centaine par manque de
moyens dans l'eure et loir démantèlement
d'un réseau de cocaïne lors de la fête
techno organisé sur une ancienne base de
l'otan
douze suspects ont été placés en garde à
vue certains sont mineurs il
appartiendrait un réseau organisé selon
les gendarmes
comme chaque année les baptêmes
collectifs devant décider l évangéliste
lors du rassemblement des tziganes dans
l'ariège à pamiers
il vend martinez et david bres
pour elle débute l'immersion dans le
royaume de dieu un plongeon dans le
monde des évangélistes tour à tour s'ils
sont baptisés au nombre des convertis
yvan il abandonne la le catholicisme
pour une autre chrétienté une heure
avant la série il envoie sa tenue de
baptême ses vêtements les plus blanc
donc son action et l'auf il évoque sa
vie d'avant
l'alcool les bagarres mais tout cela
elle bien fini désormais d'yeux et
partant jusque dans sa caravane
lui sa femme en sont convaincus le prix
hier matin et soir et le seigneur nous
aide à travailler davantage chaque jour
le seigneur ne relèvent chaque jour
l'essentiel c'est que tu sois est prêt
aujourd'hui que dieu te bénisse monde
lui les pasteurs c'est lui qui les a
convertis
nous avons à peu près 80 groupes chaque
année qui partent avec leur groupe et
leur chapiteau oui il évangélise donc là
où ils se trouvent dans toute la france
et voir aussi même l'europe pour
convertir le plus grand nombre le plus
grand nombre procès l'hippisme affiché
grâce auquel les évangélistes deegan
serait aujourd'hui plus de cent mille en
france et ces rassemblements séduisent
pas de caravane campement spartiate
ce couple n'appartient pas à la
communauté j'avais la conviction qu'il
fallait vraiment que je sois là
je pensais vraiment que c'était conduit
par dieu ait créé fallait je représente
au milieu de mes frères et soeurs gitans
même si moi je suis pas gitane dès ce
soir les évangélistes deegan plie bagage
pour repartir chez eux
sur la route les aoûtiens ont pris le
chemin du retour et déjà ils sont
remplacés arrivé en bord de mer d'une
nouvelle clientèle celle qui choisit le
mois de septembre pour sa tranquillité
ses prix avantageux avec mortes et une
vernier johann lopez chanter petit peu
spécial a souhaité la bienvenue à toutes
les personnes qui peuvent arriver et ils
sont nombreux ces touristes fraîchement
installé 135 exactement dans ce camping
est morte 25 % de la clientèle de quoi
compenser les départs
si les dates de congés de cette famille
des alpes maritimes sont différentes
c'est avant tout par obligation
professionnelle pour cette commerçante
on travaille avec les touristes
donc c'est beaucoup plus calme à la fin
de la saison et pour faire profiter mes
enfants de quelques jours de vacances
avant la rentrée scolaire en part on
part en décalé on part après les autres
et débuté son séjour fin août présente
des avantages une baisse d'environ 50%
sur les tarifs de location et surtout un
rythme différent pour la deuxième année
consécutive ce couple d'anglais
recherche la détente loin de l'afflux
touristique best of mais je préfère
venir en fin de saison
il ya alors moins d'enfants qui sait
plus qu'à ses nouveaux arrivants c'est
du jeune senior et ce sont des parents
de la tranche d'âge 25 35 avec enfants
non scolarisés ou en primaire c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent un peu raté quelques
jours d'école ou rentrer au dernier
moment des séjours plus tardif mais
surtout fragmenter les français prennent
toujours autant de vacances mais plus au
même moment une aubaine pour les
restaurateurs du littoral qui profitent
de ce morcellement depuis trop 4
c'est vrai que les gens
son parti la grosse somme assez
fortement l'alcool ça va arriver les
retraités les premières cinq et qu'ils
ont fait la saison qui mois septembre
leurs commerçants une autre clientèle
plus détendu souvent plus fortunés de
quoi compenser peut-être la médiocre
fréquentation du mois de juin
si le soleil est au rendez vous cinéma
avec la sortie mercredi prochain d'une
aventure de xavier giannoli avec
ludivine sagnier nicolas duvauchelle la
rencontre d'un jeune homme sans histoire
avec une jeune somnambule parce qu'elle
deschamps olivier robert la première
fois qu'il l'a vu c'était peut-être deux
mois après votre arrivée
pour julien l'aventuré était cette nuit
là au coin de la rue
une jeune femme est bété couverte
d'égratignures et qui rentrent se
recoucher comme si de rien n'était une
jeune femme à la vie chaotique et
violente
la promesse d'une aventure donc d'un
amour peut être un danger sûrement se
soigner ou quoi
c'est là comme vous le savez ça
julien tentera sans retenue de percer le
mystère de gabriel la somnambule pour
ludivine sagnier jouer cette partition
particulière ajoutait une dimension
passionnante du matou cc qui partait
d'un d'un cas particulier qu'est le
somnambulisme m'a tout de suite frappé
parce que ça quelque chose d'assez
original pour arriver à quelque chose de
très universel qui est simplement la
difficulté de s'accepter de ces mets
donc d'aimer l'autre
sam était prêt pour métro est une
aventure est une histoire d'amour est un
polar avec un fond de réalité
zavijah nolly a visionné les images de
somnambules en observation à l'hôpital
c'est là au moment où elle a ouvert les
yeux que la crise a commencé quand j'ai
vu des images devraient somnambule
c'était totalement hypnotisant et
stupéfiants est immédiatement
cinématographique et spectaculaire des
gens qui en pleine nuit se lève peuvent
sortir dans la rue monter dans leur
voiture peuvent frapper quelqu'un avec
un couteau
aux confins de la neurologie de la
psychiatrie le somnambulisme fascine des
médecins dans les cas extrêmes lorsqu'il
y a eu crise avec actes de violence ils
sont même appelés à témoigner au procès
ce que l'on essaie de faire pour aider à
prouver que c'est bienne au cours d'un
seul nobilise donc sans conscience du
phénomène on essaie de reproduire chez
le sujet lui-même et en laboratoire les
mêmes conditions qui ô qui on est et qui
sont survenus lors de la nuit où il ya
une somnambule liste un film troublant
avoir de préférence totalement réveillé
pour que le plaisir soit entier
la rentrée théâtrale avec le plaisir de
retrouver sur les planches jean louis
trintignant cette fois ci dans un
registre où l'on ne connais moi
enregister l'humour et la drôlerie
traite de sujets sérieux comme la
vieillesse et la mort la pièce
s'intitule -2 elle est signée samuel
benchetrit élise chassaing et laurent
des bois vous allez vous et bien en
vacances moi je viens métastases
moi je pars avant lyon ils sont vieux
ils sont malades et n'ont plus que deux
semaines à vivre sur un lit d'hôpital
bref ça a tout de la fin d'une histoire
et pas des plus drôles
pourtant ces deux là nous l'on tente pas
du tout de cette oreille pour pendre
enchanté pas question de mourir à
l'hôpital alors les vieillards taillé la
route bien au delà de son personnage
jean louis trintignant livre ici une
véritable leçon de vie j'ai besoin de
faire pour vivre des choses c'est moi je
suive vieux avec tous les tous les
inconvénients de la vieillesse j'ai tous
par exemple je suis presque aveugle je
vous vois appel
j'ai 74 ans j'ai vu beaucoup j'ai vu
beaucoup de choses
je suis déjà un corps content de voir
encore un peu il est au bout du rouleau
alors on y découvre un trintignant
facétieux porté par le cynisme et
l'humour populaire du texte de son
ex-gendre samuel benchetrit
si tu m'intéresse c'est de savoir si on
pouvait encore vivre une amitié et avoir
l'espoir de vie d'amour et de rire en
fin de parcours
donc c'était plus intéressant avec deux
personnes de cet achat puis moi je ne
sais pas pourquoi je respecte allemand
écrit reproductible
puis nous fait lire des secrets qu'on ne
dirait pas sur la vie à leur hobby mais
comme tu sais ça lui qui l'a pas 60000
et c'est ça qui est magnifique mais
c'est ça les hauteurs de trompe la mort
qui font les 400 coups dans un road
movie en pyjama surzur
fin de ce journal je remercie de votre
attention tout de suite la météo
isabelle martinet 20h50 les morfalous
avec jean paul belmondo minutes 15 le
journal de la nuit jean claude renault
demain 13h david de bohéries à 20 heures
vous retrouverez david pujadas
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2